Devil fruits in one piece sound pretty simple.
You eat the fruit.
You get a magic power.
Some of these powers are pretty simple, like
turning into an animal, while others are so
incredibly confusing and complex they feel
like a whole different power system.
In fact, even hardcore fans might not even
know that there are an incredible ELEVEN different
categories of devil fruits, each with their
own unique rules, special abilities, and powerups.
So let’s break down every single type of
devil fruit in the story.
Starting with some quick basics, which is:
what is a devil fruit?
To put it simply, this is a real fruit that
you can actually eat, with the only difference
being it has inherited a magical ability.
And to get that power all a character needs
to do is take a single bite of the fruit and
they will have their new magic power until
the day they die.
Which is rather convenient, because we are
shown over and over again that these fruits
taste like this guy after he ate the world’s
smelliest fruit.
However, there is some danger with eating
a devil fruit as well because first, it is
hard to know what power you are going to get
from a particular devil fruit.
So you might take a bite and get an awesome
lightning power or you might only be able
to turn into a cute little dog.
Plus there is only one of each power all throughout
the world.
So sorry, you and your friends can’t all
be two fire devil fruit users at the same
time.
The BIGGEST DOWNSIDE though is that once you
eat a devil fruit you lose the ability to
swim FOREVER.
And if you do happen to fall underwater, well,
you are basically doomed to drown unless there
is someone around to save you.
Which doesn’t sound all that bad until you
remember that like 90% of the one piece world
is covered by water.
So yeah, it’s a pretty big risk, especially
for a pirate who sails on the sea like our
main character Luffy.
However, most of these abilities are simply
so powerful, that eating the fruit is more
than worth the risk.
Starting with our first main category of devil
fruit, which are the Zoan fruits.
These fruits are the easiest to understand
because they simply allow the user to transform
from their human form into one specific animal
depending on the devil fruit.
And there are some other benefits that we’ll
discuss in just a moment, but of course the
user of these fruits gets all the benefits
you would think of turning into an animal.
For example, this guy who ate the Giraffe
devil fruit can now turn into a full on giraffe
and can bash people with his extra long neck
. And then we have this guy who ate the Falcon
devil fruit, so naturally he can fly with
his massive wings.
However, that is only the most basic ability
of this fruit because in addition to a full
animal transformation, the users can also
transform into an animal-human hybrid form.
This turns you into a combination of human
and animal with many of your animal characteristics,
for example, this guy who ate the leopard
fruit.
Here we can see him in his normal human form,
then his full animal form, and finally his
animal-human hybrid form.
And a skilled zoan user can change transformations
almost instantly, meaning that you can greatly
enhance your fighting ability by using the
best transformation for the situation.
And if you thought that was all there is to
these fruits, then just listen to this because
on top of everything I’ve already mentioned,
all zoan fruit users get automatic boosts
to their natural speed, strength, endurance,
and recovery.
What’s even crazier though is if your zoan
fruit is a meat-eating animal - like the leopard
guy we just showed - then you also get even
more boosts in strength and aggression due
to the animal’s natural bloodthirsty nature.
So yeah, just by eating the fruit, you basically
get a giant level up in your fighting abilities.
Now you might be surprised to learn there
are also sub-categories of zoan fruits which
get even MORE POWERFUL, but before we discuss
those, let’s talk about the ULTIMATE POWER
UP for a Zoan fruit user.
Because with any devil fruit in one piece,
the user can unlock a special level of their
fruit called Awakening.
And while it isn’t exactly spelled out how
to do this, we have some idea of how this
works.
Basically, when a person’s mind and body
catch up with the natural will of the fruit,
you can awaken the next level of the fruit.
So you mentally embrace the spirit of the
fruit and your body is skilled enough in using
the fruit.
And to stick with the leopard guy, I guess
you can say that once he fully embraced the
natural will or mindset of a leopard, he was
able to awaken his devil fruit.
Also, when normal zoans awaken your devil
fruit they get even more boosts to speed,
strength, endurance, and recovery which makes
you an absolute powerhouse capable of fighting
against the top-tier fighters in the world.
But enough about normal zoans, let’s get
to the even stronger forms of Zoan fruits.
The first of these are called Ancient Zoans,
which are still animal devil fruits, but they
represent animals or creatures from the distant
past.
For example, dinosaurs, Woolly Mammoths, and
even a Sabertooth Tiger.
And just like normal zoans, these ancient
zoan devil fruit users can transform into
their hybrid and full animal forms.
But what separates these fruits from normal
zoans is that they get an even greater boost
to all their physical abilities.
Plus, they straight up just get the awesome
powers of these ancient creatures.
I mean they can have super-hard scales, massive
claws and teeth, or even just extreme siz
which can all be super overpowered during
a fight.
As strong as Ancient Zoans are though, they
are NOTHING compared to Mythical Zoans.
And honestly, this might be the strongest
category of devil fruits in the entire story
because these fruits allow the user to become
some mythical creature of legend.
The best example of this is the Emperor of
the Sea, Kaido, whose mythical devil fruit
allows him to transform into this awesome
dragon.
I mean come on, who wouldn’t want to be
a super sized dragon.
And to make things even better, each mythical
zoan gets an extra special ability on top
of the normal zoan physical boosts and transformations.
For example, Kaido here can create elemental
attacks like his fiery blast breath that can
literally destroy mountains, summon lightning
strikes, and even create deadly tornados or
wind slashes.
And while this dragon fruit is simply overpowered,
other examples of mythical zoans are the mythical
nine-tailed fox, which allow the user to shape-shift,
and this mythical phoenix which let him to
use his blue flames to magically heal himself
and others.
Mythical zoans aren’t just restricted to
animal-like creatures either because we even
have the mythical Buddha who can shoot out
giant shockwaves from his palms.
So yeah, truly an OP type of devil fruit which
is why we currently only have nine of these
in the story.
Now, while mythical zoans may have the strongest
abilities, this next main category of devil
fruits has without a doubt the strongest base
form.
That’s right, it’s time to discuss Logia
devil fruits.
And for the longest time we thought these
were straight up the most powerful in the
story because Logia fruits turn you into the
element of substance of that devil fruit.
For example, the Lightning logia turns its
user into a lightning human and the Magma
fruit turns its user into manga.
And you might be thinking, well yeah sure,
that’s cool and all, but is it really that
OP?
Well, YES!
Because with these elemental transformations,
logia users CANNOT be hurt by normal attacks.
Any normal attack will literally just pass
right through the user.
Punches go right through this sand Logia user.
This explosion breaks this light fruit user’s
body in half, but he can quickly reform himself,
and even a spear right through the head doesn’t
bother the lightning fruit user at all.
The only way to actually damage them is by
knowing their elemental weakness, like water
against sand or rubber against lightning.
Or if you can’t do that, you can use special
anti-devil fruit stones, use haki, which is
a whole other power system we won’t get
into here, or have a stronger devil fruit
of a similar element.
But as if that wasn’t strong enough there
are even more special abilities of Logia fruit
users.
Because since their body is transformed into
their element, they can freely travel around
by completely turning into their substance.
For example, the light user can become beams
of light to chase down opponents and this
snow logia user can become a cloud of snow
to sneak up behind her enemies.
And while that is all great for defense and
movement, Logia users can also produce and
shoot out their element to fight with.
Some great examples of this are this fire
logia user shooting out fire balls, the light
logia user shooting light bullets, and even
this guy blasting off giant magma fists to
crush and burn his enemies.
Logia users can also make swords of their
element.
Plus some logia users like the swamp logia
or the darkness logia also let their users
trap people or objects inside a kinda pocket
dimension inside themselves.
Which is just INSANE that all of this is just
the normal abilities of a logia user.
Now do you believe me that these are the strongest
base form devil fruits?
And we haven’t even got to the Logia’s
ultimate power, which is of course awakening.
First, though I have to say that Logia’s
awakening has never been 100% confirmed.
However, we can roughly guess that Logia awakenings
turn their entire environment into that person’s
elemental ability.
The best possible example we have of this
is when the ice and magma logia users had
a MASSIVE fight and left an entire island
permanently changed into half frozen mountains
and half volcanic wasteland.
Now if we are considering all the categories
of devil fruits, this next main category might
be the weakest.
However, it contains what I believe are some
of the most powerful individual fruits in
the entire story.
It’s time to discuss the Paramecia devil
fruits, which can be broken into three main
subcategories.
The first of these is Body Alteration, which
basically means a devil fruit will change
the user’s body in some very specific way.
We’ve seen examples of this all throughout
the story like this guy, who has become a
blade human and can transform any part of
his body into blades.
Or this guy here who can transform any part
of his body into super hard diamond that can
even block attacks from the world’s strongest
swordsman.
But for an even crazier example, we have this
woman who can turn any part of her body into
any weapon she can imagine.
Swords, guns, massive bazookas.
You name it, she can transform into it.
Bet you’ve never seen that power in another
anime.
So yeah, Body Alteration Paramecias can change
your body in a ton of super creative ways.
But the next sub-category is even more overpowered
because we also have Environment Manipulation
Paramecias.
And instead of changing a user’s body, these
fruits give the user the ability to affect
the environment in some way.
For example, this marine admiral can alter
gravity to force people to the ground or even
pull down meteors from space.
I mean, how crazy is that?
Another perfect example is Luffy’s former
rival who can control magnetism which means
that he can pull or push any metal and create
metal body parts or weapons.
That’s just the start though because the
next subcategory of Paramecia fruits let the
user produce AND control some substance.
This is similar to Logia abilities, but these
users can ONLY produce their given substance
and control it, not completely turn into the
substance.
For example, this former Warlord can produce
a nearly endless amount of string to slash,
shoot as bullets, and even control people
like puppets.
Then there’s this little girl who can produce
these little kibi dango balls and when she
feeds them to animals will let her command
those animals around.
And just like Zoans and Logias, the Paramecia
devil fruits also have an ultimate awakening.
In general, this final power up allows the
user to directly use their power on the environment.
The easiest way to explain it is to look at
some examples like the string user actually
turning his entire environment into string
that he can then control.
Or to go back to the magnetism user, he could
make parts of his environment or even people
magnetic to trap them against a wall.
What makes Paramecias a bit more confusing
though is that there are some Paramecia’s
that don’t exactly fit into these categories.
We’ll call this the Other Category.
For example, there is this little girl’s
Parameica fruit that is absolutely broken.
Just listen to this.
With a single touch, she can turn anyone into
a little toy AND THEN force them into a contract
where they have to obey her every command.
On top of that, everybody that person ever
knew instantly forgets they even exist.
Plus this girl has her age immediately frozen,
which basically makes her forever young.
So yeah, good luck figuring out how to categorize
that fruit.
Then there is also this guy’s fruit, who
can make this magical dome where he can do
almost anything he wants within the dome.
Slice off body parts, swap personalities,
and even teleport.
He can do it all.
But the most amazing thing is this fruit has
a special ability to grant eternal youth to
one person, but it costs the fruit user their
life.
Which again is just such a broken ability
that doesn’t really fit into any of the
categories.
However, while these fruits are tough to categorize
there is one devil fruit that the author had
to officially create a brand new category
for.
This is the Mochi devil fruit, which was originally
going to be a Logia fruit, but was later changed
to a brand new category called Special Paramecia.
Now, normally Paramecia fruits get one of
the abilities we mentioned before: Body Adaptation,
Environment Manipulation, or Producing a Substance.
But what’s special about the mochi fruit
is that it has both body adaptation meaning
his body can become mochi AND he can produce
mochi.
Which almost makes it like a logia fruit,
except that the user’s body isn’t immune
to normal attacks.
And even awakening this fruit lets the user
transform his environment into sticky mochi,
so it is literally the perfect trifecta of
Paramecia powers.
The MOST MYSTERIOUS thing about all these
devil fruits though is that we aren’t entirely
sure where they came from.
I mean we do know that there is only one of
each specific devil fruit in the world at
a time.
And we also know that when a devil fruit user
dies their power is reincarnated into another
fruit so a different person can eat it.
But we don’t officially know where they
come from.
They could have originally grown on some kind
of devil fruit tree or been made scientifically
in the distant past.
In fact, this last explanation might actually
be the truth because we have seen two types
of scientifically made devil fruits in the
story.
The first type is straight up evil because
the artificial SMILE devil fruits are twisted
versions of Zoan fruits.
Basically, this SMILE fruit will give the
user some sort of animal power.
But it isn’t even a normal zoan-like transformation.
Instead you are permanently stuck with some
kind of animal part on your body like this
guy who has a lion head as a stomach or this
bat guy who just always has bat wings.
Or my favorite are these two who just look
so ridiculous.
The worst part though is that only one out
of every ten SMILE fruits actually gives you
an animal power, and the other nine leave
the people who ate them with a horrible curse
that they can only laugh for the rest of their
lives.
Seriously, these things are completely messed
up.
However, not all scientific devil fruits are
flawed because the world’s best scientist
basically perfectly recreated the mythical
dragon devil fruit which gave this boy the
exact same powers of the legendary dragon.
On top of that, this same scientist was able
to extract devil fruit DNA and recreate the
powers in genetically engineered clones.
So in theory, he could make copies of any
devil fruit power in the world, which is honestly
a scary thought.
I mean can you just imagine how terrifying
an entire army of devil fruit users would
be?
We could have ten ultra-destructive lightning
fruit users, or fifty mythical Phoenixes flying
around.
Or worst of all, what if there were one hundred
Pocket fruit users to trap everyone in their
creepy body pockets?
And those are just some of the insanely powerful
and wacky devil fruit powers in the story,
and if you want to learn about literally every
single devil fruit ability that exists in
one piece you can check out this video right
here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.